hi and i'm really excited to be here at
microsoft research summit 2021 my name
is dongsung a professor in computer
science at uc berkeley and also the
founder of oasis labs today i will talk
about towards building a responsible
data economy
as we all know data is a key driver for
modern economy and is a lifeblood of ai
and machine learning
a huge amount of data is being collected
every day
and it is estimated that a significant
portion of eu's gdp comes from value
from personalized data and the global
data economy is growing at the
exponential speed
however a lot of this data is
sensitive and both individuals and
organizations are facing unprecedented
challenges in how sensitive data is
being used
first individuals have lost control over
how their data is being used
oftentimes uses data
is misused or sold without their
knowledge and
consent
and a lot of this data is being sold
under the premise that the data has been
anonymized however volume of research
has shown that anonymization doesn't
adequately protect user's privacy so
what you see on the screen here is an
example
a case study that new york times has
done showing that from anonymized mobile
phone location data sets that they were
able to obtain they were able to track
the location of a secret service agent
with former president trump and hence
also
revealing the information about the
location and trajectory of former
president trump and data breaches
continue to plague businesses many
large-scale attacks
have stolen sensitive information about
hundreds of millions of users of
billions of users
in
each one of these attacks
and also
businesses now
is becoming much more expensive and
cumbersome for businesses to comply with
privacy regulations such as ccpa and
gdpr and the bigger issue is
that
a lot of valuable data is being locked
up in data silos
and
now being able
to be utilized due to privacy concerns
so today
we are already seeing facing huge
challenges
in how to utilize
sensitive data
to the
extent that
these problems if not addressed they
will significantly hinder societal
progress
and to the extent that
it will undermine human values and
fundamental rights
and thus we have an urgent need for a
framework for a responsible data economy
what do i mean by a responsible data
economy what are the goals and
principles of a responsible data economy
so first we need to establish and
enforce data rights data rights form the
foundation of data economy and prevent
misuse and abuse of data
and we would also like to enable
fair distribution of value created from
data such that users can gain sufficient
benefits from their data and ultimately
we would like to enable efficient data
use to maximize social welfare and
economic efficiency so that data can be
utilized for individuals organizations
governments and society's best interests
there are many unique challenges and
complexity due to the nature of data so
first there's natural tension between
utility and privacy on one hand we want
to utilize data to extract value out of
data on the other hand we need to be
able to protect uh privacy of users data
and also data has a unique property
called the non-reverie which is
different from physical objects so with
the physical objects for example if i
hold
an apple in my hands then nobody else
can be holding the same apple at the
same time so this is called rivalry
however for data data is different data
has nature of
being non-rival meaning that
if i hold a copy
of a piece of data then somebody else
can hold a copy of the same piece of
data and
they can utilize the data just as well
as i can in this case
and hence
due to this non-rivalry property
once data is given out
is copied one can never really take the
data back and data also has properties
such as data dependency and data
externality for example process data can
review information about the original
data because the process data has been
computed from the original data and also
data about one entity can review
information about another entity because
of these
unique properties of data
we can now simply copy concepts and
methods in the analog world instead we
need to develop a new framework for a
responsible data economy
and this requires a combination of
technical and non-technical solutions in
particular a framework for a responsible
data economy needs to have at least
three components technical solutions
incentive models and legal framework so
first let me talk about the technical
solutions the traditional solutions are
insufficient in traditional solutions
data encryption has mainly been used to
protect data at rest or in transit
and data is not really protected when
being
in use and in fact data is either now
used all once used is often copied and
thus making it difficult to control
future usage of the data and also as i
mentioned earlier
anonymizing data is often insufficient
to protect users data privacy so we need
to develop new technologies in
particular to protect data while data is
in use and in order to achieve this we
need to address two main goals one is
that we need to be able to enable
contribute use of data so that data can
be used without having to copy the raw
data and second we also need to be able
to protect the computation outputs from
leaking sensitive information
about the original input
luckily in the research community there
has been huge advancements in developing
new technologies to address these issues
and i call this technology responsible
data technologies and given the
complexity of the issue and the
different aspects for addressing
the issue we need to have different
component technologies together
to enable responsible data use
in particular here i list four examples
of components technologies
including secure computing such as using
secure hardware and pc
fully hormonal encryption so to keep
data confidential even when data
is in use by application and
differential privacy helps protect the
computation output from leaking
sensitive information
and fair digital learning
utilizes secure computing and
differential privacy
and enable data to stay at
the data owner's devices without leaving
the data owner's devices and enable
distributed data analytics and model
training
across
different devices
and finally with distributed ledger it
helps provide an immutable log of user's
data rights and how data has been
utilized to ensure that data usage is
compliant
so first let me talk
briefly about the first component
technology
secure computing the goal of secure
computing is to protect the computation
process from leaking sensitive
information and there are different
types of technologies for secure
computing including using secure
hardware as well as cryptographic based
tech techniques such as secure
multi-party computation
and fully homomorphic encryption the
challenge for cryptographic based
approaches is that the performance
overheads often can be very high and can
be octaves of magnitude higher than
native computation and hence
can only support special purpose
computation in the
recent years there has been a huge
advancement in improving performance
overhead for these cryptographic-based
methods such as homomorphic encryption
and multi-party uh computation
however and still
um today there's still a huge gap in
terms of the
the performance enabled by these
cryptographic based approaches
versus what is really needed in practice
for
uh computation with practical
large-scale workload
for example today
using hormone marker encryption and npc
methods
for training for example machining
models
on certain
real worlds
data sets it can still take
an
orders of magnitude slower than native
computation and for example training
image nets
um
with vgg16 takes
many years to do using these type of
approaches so another type of approach
is to use uh secure hardware the
advantage of using secure hardware is
that the performance overheads is much
lower often times close to native
performance and
hence can be used to support general
purpose computation and for secure
hardware usually it utilizes a
combination of hardware and software
mechanisms to provide an isolated
execution environment often called a
secure enclave when applications are
running inside the secure enclave
nothing
outside for example including the
operating system and other applications
will be able to
modify
the data inside the secure enclave and
its execution are
seeing information learning information
about the the data and execution running
inside the
secure enclave enhanced provides
integrity and confidentiality for
computation in the secure enclave and
also secure enclave provides a
capability called the remote at the
station to enable a remote verifier to
verify the initial state of the secure
enclave and the program that's running
inside the secure enclave and hence
provides a remote verification of the
computation inside the secure enclave
given its strong security capabilities
secure enclaves can serve as a
cornerstone security primitives
and that enable a platform for building
new security applications that couldn't
be built otherwise for the same
practical performance
given as importance
different hardware manufacturers have
been developing
different solutions for secure hardware
however all these are
closed source in order to truly enable
trustworthy secure enclave i strongly
believe that we need a open source
solution for secure hardware this will
help us to
provide the security assurance that's
needed for actually a trustworthy secure
enclave and towards the school at
berkeley we have been developing a
project called the keystone
which provides a first open framework
for building
a customizable
secure hardware also called trusted
execution environments tees
keystone is built on top of risk 5
which is open source risk architecture
and
it utilizes
capabilities memory isolation
capabilities provided by risk 5 and
enables a modular and flexible design
to enable a minimum transient computing
base
that
can
better facilitate formal verification
with keystone
from our experiments
we show that uh
the performance overheads can be close
to native uh performance for for example
for different machining benchmarks and
other
benchmarks and today you can try out
keystone on the latest risk 5 boards as
well as
using fpgas and also
emulation
and keystone is now supported by the
confidential computing consortium with
the global members
of different leading technology
companies and other entities i strongly
believe that in 10 years secure
computing will become a common place in
10 years most
chips will have secure enclave
secure execution environment
capabilities and in 10 years most
computation will utilize secure enclaves
and also in 10 years hardware
accelerators for cryptographic methods
for secure computation will also be
widely available
so that's the first component technology
and for
secure computing
now let me briefly talk about the second
component technology differential
privacy to motivate why we need
differential privacy
first let me um
illustrate with some recent case studies
that we have done so in our recent work
in collaboration with researchers from
google and other places we said how to
explore the question do your neural
networks remember training data if yes
can attacker
utilize or exploit
this issue
and to be able to
extract secrets in the original training
data from just simply querying the
learned models so
in this case study we focus on language
models so with language models
it's changed over a corpus of text and
when given a sequence of words or
characters the language model will
predict the next word or the next
character so for example language models
has had
white
applications and adoption for example in
smart compose and so on so the question
is
in this case can attackers
by just simply occurring the learned
model
actually learn sensitive information in
the original training data so this is an
interesting example
that in this case the attacker was able
to
by utilizing the learn model
to really
identify and learn sensitive information
about the revolution
so in
our case study here is an example where
we show that the key study here is to
change a language model an email data
set calls the enron email data set the
annual email data set actually contained
actual users credit card and social
security numbers our workshop that's an
attacker without knowing
the
any details of the
model including the model architecture
and
the parameters of the model
by just simply occurring the learned
model the attacker is able to
automatically extract
users credit card and social security
numbers that were embedded in the
original training data
so this is an example illustrating and
that as we train machining the models is
important
to take precaution to protect users
to protect the privacy of users data in
our work we also propose a measure
called exposure to measure the degree of
memorization and
it has been utilized in for example
google smart compose to help
improve
privacy protection in our more recent
work we also extended the work to study
larger language larger scale language
models such as gpt2 and we have
developed new attacks illustrating that
even for uh for these large scale
language models similar
issues also
appears
and attackers in this case by just
occurring the
gbt2 model for example is able to
to extract personally identifiable
information that has been used in the
training data set so what can we do in
in this case how can we
trim better machining models
that provides better protection for
user's data privacy in this case in our
work we show that in certain cases
we can utilize solutions such as
differential privacy to help address the
issue so for example in the earlier work
we showed that by training a
differentially private language model
instead of a vanilla language model in
certain cases we can still maintain a
similar
utility for the model and at the same
time we can significantly enhance the
privacy protection for users data from
these chains
models so differential privacy is
a formal notion of privacy that helps
protect
users data from the data analytics and
machining models computers from these
from users original data but however
deploying differential privacy in
practice
has many challenges in our work we have
developed automated techniques to
to enable uh automatic rewriting of anal
data analytics programs to automatically
embed differential privacy mechanisms
into data analytics queries
such that one doesn't need to change the
back end of the original database and
also the data analyst doesn't need to
know anything about differential privacy
this rewritten and data analysis query
will then automatically produce
differentially private results and hence
make it easy to deploy differential
privacy and also at the same time
to be able to provide automatic
protection for users data privacy and
also in our reason where can we also
develop a new higher other language and
type system to be able to statically
analyze programs and in this language
and to enforce
differential privacy we are able to
automatically compute
the privacy banks
and
enhance be able to automatically prove
differential privacy for example machine
learning algorithms and so on and our
work is one the distinguished paper was
at uh top
uh programming program language
conference uh uppsala and some of our
work has been deployed and piloted at a
different industry so um given the
interest of time i won't be able to go
into the details for all these different
component technologies and when we
combine these different component
technologies uh including secure
computing differential privacy federal
learning and distribute ledger we can
build a secure distributed computing
fabric that can serve as the platform
for a responsible data economy
so here is
a quick workflow how one these component
technologies are put together can enable
this platform for a responsible data
economy so in this case the data
provider
can provide bundles of data together
with its desire the policy of how data
is being utilized for example data may
be only used for training differentially
private machining models and so on and
the data will be encrypted in this case
together uh bundled with the data use
policy and this information can then be
committed to a blockchain which provides
the immutable ledger for this data
rights and data use policy and now when
under the analyst and the consumer wants
to use the data the data analysts can
submit
the analytics and machine learning
program that will
that the data analyst wants to run on
the data and now access controller will
take the latest data use policy from the
blockchain for the data and also the
analyst program and the access
controller
also has a static analyzer component
which will check the policy against the
program and also outputs what we call a
residual policy that governs the use of
the competition results and if the
aesthetic analyzer checks that the
program is compliant with the use policy
of the data and will then send the proof
of the policy compliance to a
distributed key manager then the access
controller will then also instantiate a
trusted execution environment and the
date the encrypted data will be loaded
in the trusted execution environment and
the
the distributed key manager can then
send the decryption key
to the traffic execution environment
then the data can be decrypted and the
computation can be done and then the
computer results will then be encrypted
with the residue policy and this
information will then also be committed
to the blockchain and also provides an
immutable log for how the data has been
utilized and this encrypted results
depending on the residual policy can
then be further utilized for example the
analysts can download the results can
query training models around additional
programs that satisfies the residue
policy
and also the data provider in this case
can inspect the blockchain to see how
their data has been utilized so overall
this
distributed secure computing platform
can then be utilized to support what i
call data commons for decentralized data
science so in this setting the data
owners data producers they will register
their data sets with the policy
specified
and to a distributed data catalog and
the data consumer and data analyst can
then search this distributed catalog and
as it finds relevant data i can write
the analytics and machine learning
programs over these different datasets
and data sources and submit the program
to this distributed platform that i
described earlier and this distributed
platform executing platform can then
provide
uh distributed secure computing while
ensuring that the program is compliant
with the desired policies so
then
enables privacy preserving utilization
of data from distributed
data sources this approach can help
reduce friction of data use remove data
silos and enforce
strong security and privacy protection i
strongly believe that in 10 years data
trust and in the comments will become
predominant ways of utilizing diverse
sources of data and enabling ownership
economy where users benefit from their
data as owners and partners in ten years
data stewards futures and trustees will
be a new class of entities important in
the data ecosystem managing and
protecting users data and growing its
value
and in 10 years huge economic value will
be created through
these new forms of data trust and data
commons orders are magnitude higher than
today's data marketplace and when we
combine
privacy computing and blockchain it can
also enable a new type of assets that
are called data assets in this case
blockchain helps
enable
providing an immutable lock of users
rights to data and
data use policies
and also help enforce the use policies
it's being satisfied and with the
privacy computing it can ensure that
data remains private during compute and
cannot be reused without permission and
this capsule of data and policies can
create a new type of asset that i call
data assets that helps users to
both protect
their data privacy and also at the same
time and to gain value from their data
and with this approach with data
accession we can unlock a new
responsible data economy where users and
businesses can maintain data rights and
earn value from their data assets
and in our recent work at oasis labs we
have been
putting this
approach into practice and in particular
we have developed technologies to help
uh users to maintain control of their
genomic data and also at the same time
to enable their data to be utilized in a
privacy presuming way and enable data
users to be able to gain value from
their data as well so so far i have
focused on the
first components of a responsible data
economy the technical solutions
so now i will briefly talk about this
the two other components incentive
models and legal frameworks so we need
to have uh better incentive models for
example how to determine and distribute
value of data existing data evaluation
approaches are ad hoc and insufficient
in our recent work we have showed that
we can model machine learning as a
collisional game and
utilize the concept of sharply value to
define and to build a rigorous framework
to show that how we can distribute value
created from machine learning models to
the data contributors a given interest
of time i won't go through the details
of shareplay value
and at a high level sharply value
computes for each player
essentially as expected marginal
contribution of the players data
to the trained machining models to the
utility function and
we have developed
efficient algorithms to compute sharply
value for
training machining models
with large-scale data and we also need
to establish
legal frameworks to help address some of
the open challenges regarding to data
rights
for example what are the rights and who
can choose data rights individual
property rights are a cornerstone of
modern economy and has helped establish
modern economics and filled centuries of
significant growth and today we lack an
adequate framework for data rights
establishing data rights will allow
individuals to derive value from their
data and propel economic growth and
unlock new value
and there has been diverse concepts and
frameworks proposed in this space and
overall we need data-driven
technology-informed regulation for
example how will advancements of
responsible data technology influence
and impact regulatory frameworks and how
can regulation help with faster and
broader adoption of responsible data
technology
for the future of the internet we must
build a responsible data economy and the
2020s is a decade for building a
responsible data economy
thank you